president joe biden long distracted by
global crises is now turning his
attention eastward to asia with the
global pandemic and the war in ukraine
still raging the u.s president embarks
on his first trip to the region as
president considerably later in his term
than expected he begins in seoul in a
show of solidarity with allies working
to counter the regional dominance of
china the
biden investigation is not very
different from the trump administration
and its policy toward china
the rhetoric may not be as
confrontational but the policies have
remained the same the threats from china
both military and economic also remain
the same the us government's view on
china like bidens has been evolving ever
since president richard nixon made a
visit there in 1972
biden who visited china as senator in
2001 and as vice president in 2011 has
gone from seeing it as a partner to be
liberalized through trade to a sharp
elbow rival
china has an overall goal
and i don't criticize them for the goal
but they have an overall goal to become
the leading country in the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
president trump spoke more fondly but
waged a bitter trade war against him
better my relationship with president xi
is an extraordinary one
he's for china i'm for the u.s but other
than that we love each other in seoul
biden will also press to work out the
kinks in the global supply chain
and work on north korea the
goal remains the same
which is the impossible goal and that is
the denuclearization of the korean
peninsula it's not going to happen then
biden travels to tokyo for a meeting of
the quadrilateral security dialogue
australia india japan and the u.s
focused on trade security he's expected
to emphasize that the region remains a
top u.s priority we're committed to a
future where
the rules and norms that have made
possible so much growth and prosperity
and stability in the pacific are upheld
and strengthened
a priority the white house says despite
the war and pandemic that have consumed
much of his presidency john hendren al
jazeera
let's get more on the visit from al
jazeera's florence louis who's in seoul
what message is the u.s intending to
send
with this visit florence
well south korea and japan are already
key allies of the us but the us says it
wants to strengthen those ties even
further and we're likely to see that
take the form of perhaps new trade and
business and technology deals perhaps an
upgrading of existing security
partnerships now it's also important to
note that just a week ago president
biden hosted southeast asian leaders in
the u.s and at that summit analysts say
it wasn't part of an effort to prevent
china from dominating the indo-pacific
region so this trip really is to rally
its
allies in east asia to send a message to
its friends and allies and also a
message to china that the u.s is back
it's committed to the region and it
wants the indo-pacific to remain free
and open and this is a message that
we've heard the biden administration
make time and again
now for countries in this region however
china remains a very important partner
especially in trade so for them it's not
going to be a matter of having to choose
which country they want to align
themselves to but more of
committed but more of conducting a fine
balancing act between these two powerful
nations and what specifically is the
president hoping to achieve there in
south korea
well denuclearization of north korea is
going to be high on the agenda
especially given reports that north
korea could be conducting a seventh
nuclear test but trade and technology is
also very important for both the us and
also south korea um we've seen the world
um go through a shortage of computer
chips and that's had an effect on the
availability of vehicles of kitchen
appliances and other goods that supply
chain crunch has had an effect has
contributed rather to inflation and the
us is keen to prevent those problems
come going forward so one way to do that
is to have those chips manufactured in
the u.s and at the moment the u.s only
produces about 10 percent of computer
chips so the plant
and it's significant that president
biden his first trip or his first visit
rather in south korea is going to be a
visit to a samsung chip manufacturing
plant and that plant is going to serve
as a model for a plant that samsung is
building in the u.s now president biden
is also expected to make a case for a
bill that he once passed that will see
the u.s bolster chip production and also
help protect it from future supply chain
problems in asia now it's not just a win
for u.s it's also a win for south korea
it's already an important player in the
chip industry but obviously it wants a
bigger market share and its tie-ups with
the u.s will help it do that because
more plants means more outputs and
greater market share
florence many thanks indeed al jazeera's
flores louis there live in seoul